but what do you notice just about this
image that's on the screen right now
well they've blocked out all of the
genitalia so that I can't see it but the
children can that's a really good thing
exact warning this episode may contain
content that is not suitable for
children viewer discretion is advised
have you noticed an increasing amount of
inappropriate content being thrown at
young children find out on this episode
of LED live
thank you
Darkness welcome to LED live everybody
where we get to expose some Darkness
with the Light of Christ and here on
this show we are gonna tackle some
difficult subject matter we have a guest
here today Michael carducci thank you
for coming on board to be here and uh as
you will see in a second there's a
reason why we wanted to do this show
with Michael here
um because we've had you on the show
before discussing some some topics of
sexuality and um I remember I think it
was almost two years ago you had
mentioned how we're gonna start to see a
lot more of this type of content being
thrown at young kids and so here we are
two years later we're starting to see
the effects of that and um we want to
discuss it great
so thanks for coming on board yeah yeah
we want to get your live reaction of
some of these things because some of
this is shocking you know I don't know I
bet you get a lot of stuff and emails
from people that are like you wouldn't
believe this so maybe you've seen this
before but I'm curious to hear what you
guys say about it yeah yeah I really
have no idea you know why I'm sitting
here and you guys have kept it a secret
but um
I'm surprised
um continually about how far and
degraded our our world is uh in regards
to what we think is healthy sexuality
um if you can go back uh probably 60 70
years ago Alfred Kinsey was a homosexual
pedophile masochist who did a lot of
research and he was funded by the um the
Rockefellers Rockefeller he was funded
by the Rockefeller Institute and he did
experiments on children to discover when
they were sexual as a matter of fact in
his research he determined that I think
the child was
um an infant six-month-old infant uh
female was orally and digitally
stimulated and they determined that this
child within 24 hours of being kept
awake had a series of 22 orgasms and
they determined that an orgasm was uh
screaming vomiting and passing out oh
man and this is where we get our our
education system about sex education
they're so disgusting that that anybody
would even think this is okay but this
happened years and years ago they made
him a hero because there was a movie
that came out I think it's called Kinsey
and it came out a couple of years ago
and they basically made him out to be
this victim that was really
misunderstood and he did a lot of really
good things and Liam Neeson even plays
him in the role so it totally glamorizes
everything that Kinsey was about so
again the whole idea to deceive you into
thinking that this is healthy and normal
yeah well we're starting to see a little
bit of a trend and and stuff kind of
gets sent to us over the year years and
this past year there was a couple videos
that were sent to us that we just love
to to get your opinion on
um because we're seeing this over
sexualization of children like being
like you know promoted in in throughout
the world we'll show you a little video
here
um this first one is actually
um some dolls that were released in the
United States
um and these dolls are known as LOL
dolls
um a lot of kids had them but there was
a surprise when you got the doll and
here's a little bit of the surprise when
you take the doll and you actually dip
it in iced water that
um you you would have to remove the
clothing off the doll there were some
things that would show up on this doll
if you can kind of make that out it's uh
lingerie wow now why would they put
lingerie on a doll
I mean that just that just seems like
highly inappropriate not only do young
children not even understand what that
clothing would be all about but you know
children are very impressionable and if
these little images and that's what
happens you play with the toys those
images kind of stick inside your mind
and then down the road they may not
understand where they're getting these
ideas or these thoughts from but I find
this um highly inappropriate this is a
no no surprise so the other one was the
LOL surprise this is not on our surprise
not sure if they're by the same company
but well it's interesting for someone as
old as me they've dressed this doll up
to with a poodle skirt which is typical
of 1950s yeah and this is actually more
conservative than like the LOL dolls
there they're more Punk and they got you
know Spike bracelets and Mohawks and
stuff to me this would be more of
something like if you were more of a
conservative parent you might would buy
the poodle dress at all you know not
knowing what's underneath the dress and
so
um this is another one that uh has an
entire lingerie outfit underneath the
dress
I mean what's the
having a child play with it that's like
this specifically marketed to Children
yes oh yeah yeah wow well we're already
seeing the effects of of these dolls
because it started long before these
dolls came out when you look at children
today
um I I know the conservative parents
really struggle with how to dress their
children because they say that a lot of
the clothes show crop tops for little
six-year-olds and you know uh shorts
that are really short and and you know
different clothes like that so the whole
idea that has come through fashion is
about uh sexualizing our children and
the sooner that you sexualize a child
and they they watch Britney Spears let's
just use Britney Spears and uh Hannah
Montana as two perfect examples they
started off very sincere and innocent
you know Britney Spears was supposedly a
virgin and the whole idea is that now
you look at these two individuals and
the example that they gave us as pure
and wholesome and now they're completely
you know on the other side and open
sexuality I think that
um again Miley Cyrus she identifies as
pansexual so the whole idea is you know
get them when you're young you know hook
them and then change them as a matter of
fact I saw your video last night or no
this morning of the guy that you know
did the rodeo thing and now he's like
doing lap dances for Satan all of that
is designed specifically to warp and to
change the minds of your children and
and if a parent is innocent enough not
to know what this is all about or to see
that Trend the idea is again to bypass
the parents get the child hooked and
then when a child grows up it's like oh
I can be a Satanist I can do all these
kind of things because these are things
that I learned at a very young age so
you're just seeing the continuation of
objectifying our children into thinking
that they're sexual even as a child who
knows X so
yeah yeah you used it before like smells
good right yeah a few years ago I
actually stopped using it because if you
look at the back of the bottle there's
very suggestive imagery and I am raising
three boys in my house and it's like I
didn't want them to be seeing it like I
love the smell I like it was my soap
brand right you know but you have to
move away from that otherwise here's all
these extra ideas that they're getting
on the back of a bottle now I've seen
the commercials and they're very
suggestive yeah they're very intent on
making it about sex but I didn't know it
was actually on the labeling but you
think about you know as a as a young
child you bring up a good point you have
kids who are gonna in a subliminal way
get exposed to that kind of a thing and
then later on when they're an adult or
they're looking around on the Internet
or watching YouTube videos or something
like this they're going to get exposed
to those commercials and that's going to
register something that they've been
already priorly exposed to it's like
that's the purpose of this soap you know
it's kind of like you're in conclusion
you read through the story and this is
you know the whole point at the end
but that propaganda has been around for
more than 100 years you know they asked
Madonna back in the 80s why she had so
many references to homosexuality in her
music videos and she said well some
people will be disgusted but some people
will be arousing eventually after they
see it over and over again it's no big
deal and now we look at television today
and that every sitcom has a gay
character uh you have gay romance now in
commercials and and so it's basically
the the boiling of the frog in the pot I
think that another thing that's um
that's been happening for a long time is
if what Kenzie was saying is that even
children are sexualized then again these
dolls are necessary to start
implementing those thoughts in your kids
heads because remember when we were kids
oh I don't I remember when I was a kid
bell bottoms were the rage and my
parents they said no they cost like ten
dollars more we're not buying you that
you know these jeans are just fine but I
could go to Grandma and grandma would
always get me the bell bottom jeans well
why did I want bell bottom jeans because
I was being
um motivated and manipulated by the
culture that's right and so all the
other kids had Bell Bottom Jeans I
needed bell bottom jeans and eventually
it was bib overalls and then it was a
pea coat so so the whole idea is that
when you get kids to think that this is
necessary and that this is a good thing
then it works with peer pressure and you
start to change and shape uh Generations
even before they're adults and you start
to see actually
um you know my kids they luckily my
daughter never really got into the whole
doll phase
um but I I have been to toy stories with
my daughter and walked down the aisles
and just like is amazing at how scantily
dressed these little dolls are or
something like this and I'm sure that's
got to have an impact upon when those
girls get to be teenagers and you know
it's like well I've been playing with
dolls for the last 10 years you know why
not dress like that so I can see this as
yes is a precursor to you know priming
them for something down the road but
it's funny even in my generation we had
stuff like that but it wasn't as overt I
remember we had candy cigarettes and it
was great to buy a pack of candy
cigarettes and put them in your pocket
and you know put one in your mouth or
whatever and had a red tip on an end uh
we also had uh fake tattoos you know
you'd wet them and put them on your arm
and it would leave a tattoo all of that
helps to shape our our understanding to
think that these things are a lot of fun
to play with but then they put inside
the mind that yeah one day I want a real
tattoo or you know lead you into smoking
I think that the uh candy cigarettes
were actually made illegal at some point
because somebody saw the connection
between how it shapes children and draws
them into smoking well you know what's
kind of funny about that is that that's
kind of a piece of Truth saying that if
you play with this that is going to have
a real world result over here right so
for all the people that are like
whatever it's just a toy you're making a
big deal about a toy why would you
remove something like that off of the
line saying if you play with this thing
down the road you may be a real smoker
absolutely like a Harry Potter or wizard
of wand or something oh no big deal and
then five years later they're that one
in the occult yeah right yeah you were
exposed to it so
um so we want to kind of progress a
little bit further from this there was a
show that came out
um I believe that this one was from the
Netherlands and uh this was quite kind
of alarming to me that this is not a
public joke or that this is actually a
real thing but
um I'll play a little bit of the intro
to the thing
um this is a claymation it is a
children's it is for children yeah
so this is um something that was put out
specifically for kids and it is a
gentleman
um
okay I'll just let you see it and we'll
we'll see what you think of it John do
you like that already
[Music]
don't need
them I guess so I guess that was it so
that was the intro so could we go back
just a little bit to um when she shot
him with the gun because even that was
precarious right
the gun came out yeah you know she
wasn't holding it like a you know like a
regular rifle it was down here yeah like
all these little puns and stuff in a
children's show
now they say that there's nothing sexual
about it it's just a piece about that
the design the makers I said that this
show isn't meant to be sexual anyway
it's just a funny cartoon about another
you know about part of his body so what
entry is this again Netherlands that's
right so what it like it's not a string
that goes around it's not his belt it's
not you know they're open about what it
is yeah they are his name actually the
dillerman is actually a term in their
country that describes what's up yeah
it's basically means penis man okay so
so then they give it away yeah they say
that's sexual and it's interesting that
they use his dillerman to be the
underlying you know even in the title
yeah right they underline it with his
with his thing yeah
so you know I mean how how just
inappropriate is this that any child
would be exposed to this and bringing
attention to a a you know male ballast
private parts yeah
and and then
um you know not even kind of giving a
clear context of of why do we have those
parts what are those parts for you know
it's like almost sort of making fun of
the use of it with really even not even
discussing any real proper context of it
sure actually but Scotty I I think also
what you have is um it's kind of like
grinding down our moral values and you
know that happened even years ago I
remember seeing the movie Aladdin you
know with Robin Williams and I remember
thinking oh finally you know a kids show
that I can actually enjoy and you think
that the kids don't get the sexual
innuendos in the movie but they're still
exposed to it and you know that happened
even to me with like other movies you
know there would be sexual innuendo and
as a kid
I didn't necessarily understand it fully
but I did get it yeah we knew that there
was something you're like what I've seen
it you know with my own daughter you me
or my wife will laugh about something
then they won't leave you alone about it
what what was it what was funny about it
what they they know they're missing out
on the joke so if they're not going to
get it from you well let me find what
was funny about this or whatever but but
incredibly intelligent too I mean
they're perceiving more than I think we
give them credit for yeah
I think that um anyone that would say
that that's not a sexual cartoon when
the actual name of it is called the
dillerman and that implies a male
phallus and then it's underlined by his
dillerman like you can't even deny what
your intention was about that cartoon
but what they're getting at is that why
just because this part of the body was
it have to be sexual I can do sexual
things with other parts of my body but
they're not sexual they're trying to
de-sexualize things just like I remember
seeing ads on Facebook
um from the news and stuff saying that
they wanted to make it where girls could
remove their tops it was a you know a
sex discrimination that women if they're
hot why can't they take their tops off
and so I would get involved in those
conversations and be like so you're
saying
that you think a little 13 year old girl
bouncing around at the playground can do
that with her shirt off as old men or on
the playground watching their grandkids
or whatever and they're like oh you're a
pervert why would you even think that
because I have a daughter and you know
and and for you know if somebody has a
son should they be exposed to uh topless
a grown woman walking down the street
and then so it works both ways you're
gonna expose adults to young children or
you're going to expose young children to
the adults and instead of just accepting
the fact of logic they try to flip it
and oh you're a pervert for even
thinking that way or whatever no I'm
gonna think that way I have a daughter
who's 10 years old
and and it is kind of an alarming
thought to me like you know not
necessarily that my kids would ever be
exposed to something like this but my
kids could potentially be around other
kids that are potentially exposed to
this type of a thing right and so it's
just kind of I I think as a parent to
due diligence to be aware of what's
actually out there and so that we we
actually need to really kind of
um
um bring these topics up at an age
appropriateness a time that we you know
your child you don't want to prematurely
expose them when they have no clue what
it is anyway but
um I think we as a as a as a church and
even as parents we need to do a better
job at at teaching the proper context of
sexuality because this is what's coming
into the world the the thing with this
one in particular like aside from their
you know whatever they they think okay
well we're not trying to do anything
here what just aside from your
attentions if you look up
um what they say about his character it
says it's aimed at children four to
eight okay and then there was another
part here yeah it's right above this
it's a comedy about a man
whose giant member gets him in all sorts
of trouble so they even said it yeah it
says it that to me says okay so this is
what's getting him in trouble as if
he doesn't have any control over himself
and to me that's that's the real big
issue is like oh you know it's it's not
his fault it's like this is just the way
it is you know this is just getting him
in trouble kind of like it's funny but
you look in the world today there's all
kinds of people who are blaming
everything but themselves and getting
themselves in trouble for all kinds of
inappropriate behaviors yeah and so to
me this is like the first step into that
and you're showing it to children and
implanting that idea that oh you know
it's just a funny thing look at him get
in trouble and and a two-edged sword of
this is also children that are exposed
to this and maybe will kind of gather
that sort of context there that like
okay well he can't just control himself
it's almost like you're knocking down
their natural defenses around adults
that okay well I remember this show and
they couldn't really control themselves
there and this adults here at church she
can't really control himself either and
yeah you know I think you're you're
doing a bad service to your child yeah
back to the monkey see monkey do type
thing you know you're you're gonna see
this what if an eight-year-old is around
what if an eight-year-old male is around
your six-year-old daughter and he's
swinging this thing around
it's not sexual why am I in trouble for
doing what the cartoon did you know what
if they try to press charges well we
can't repress charges he didn't do
anything sexual he was just swinging his
member around like the cartoon he saw I
went I want to get back to the control
aspect though
so many of our
sins go back to self-control which is
one of the fruits of the spirit yeah
right you remove the ability for
self-control and it's open season on
just about every topic every sin
everything you God has said in in the
Bible in Galatians chapter five you know
one of the fruits of the spirit is
self-control like when when you remove
that I mean look at the anti-diluvian
world right
their thoughts were only evil
continually it's like no restraint no
self-control so they did lawlessness
what was evil in their own eyes but I
did what was right
God's government really survives off of
boundaries I mean there are boundaries
that you cannot go beyond and and and
that's a loving
um you know you you wouldn't steal from
somebody it's not your stuff why would
you take that there's a boundary there
right whereas the devil's kind of
flipping that whole thing and saying
well that's holding me back from
something you should be able to do
whatever you want to do and I think
sexuality is just one of those those
things that's just getting pushed
further and further and further and I
mean we'll see that there's there's a
there's a destructiveness that happens
in the mind from this kind of thing I've
heard it explained as as guard rails
let's say you know when you're on the
interstate you see these metal guard
rails on either side
you won't actually die if you step on
the other side of that guard rail
there's usually
you know four feet of concrete still
before you go off into the ditch but the
guard rail is placed further to keep you
from even getting close to the edge now
something like this
there's a reason that you don't have
somebody
uh you know playing with the remember
even if it's not in a sexual context
you're removing a guard rail now you're
just getting one step closer to the edge
you know well I want to add to that mic
because I think it's actually closer to
uh sex sexual abuse because children
aren't sexually
um motivated naturally and it's usually
a puberty that children become awakened
by their members and I remember as a
child I was never molested and so to me
that was only one function and that was
to urinate and and so the idea of you
know you start focusing on this this
phallus with this man or whatever and a
six-year-old kid is looking at it what
it does is all of a sudden it puts your
attention to something that you
naturally wouldn't have the attention to
and then all of a sudden there's more
exploration going on
um using the example of my colleague Ron
Woolsey he was molested at four years
old by an adult male and he said at that
moment he was awakened sexually and not
only did he start wetting the bed but he
also started
um this behavior of being preoccupied
about you know men's members because
that's the first sexual introduction
that he had so this is in essence a
sexual
um exposure abuse that well right
because of the exposure you know
children that are naturally
um thinking about that and all of a
sudden it's like oh kids start looking
to go oh I can tie it to a bus or I can
you know use it as a helicopter when
those thoughts wouldn't naturally come
to their mind what I find really
insulting by this cartoon is the fact
that it looks like it was designed and
written by um an eight-year-old you know
eight-year-olds are all you know focused
on their thing and right you know what
they can do with it and this is like um
so extreme in the imagination like
whatever adult may have put this
together I'm thinking was either smoking
an inordinate amount of crack or
whatever but it's it's insulting even to
to an intelligence I think of an
eight-year-old I don't know what's more
alarming the fact that that you can make
a show like this and people aren't just
like immediately mortified by this kind
of content or that somebody is literally
sitting there in a in a in a Adult World
saying I want to create something for a
four-year-old you know what I mean like
like is it is it
I mean multiple signatures yeah okay
okay you know what I mean this is not
one person going I'm making a YouTube
channel wait wait wait but would it
surprised you more if one of those
signatures was the uh education
coordinator for the Netherlands yes
let's send this out PBS wouldn't that be
even actually I think did work with them
I was just guessing Okay so we're going
to read before we're going to read
through this a little bit more here
later on in this article it says this
first episode
um sees John dillerman tending to a
barbecue from afar which was watched by
more than 250
000 children in five days this is not a
YouTube show where not very many people
are being affected by this this is a
large amount of people that are being
exposed to this they call it a huge
success yes yeah wow no pun intended you
guys remember when Michelle was here I
love the illustration she gave
um
this show is seeking to uncover to not
make this so taboo and that's the devil
anyway though he's always trying to
uncover but we all have phones at this
table and each one of them has a cover
on it so we're viewing something as a
cell phone as more delicate something
that needs to be protected more than our
own Temple that's that's really it's
kind of scary good point not even us but
our children yeah as well right I think
as a parent
um this is a very dangerous device to
handle your child yeah I mean literally
uh this you know this device can get
your child into more trouble than you
could possibly ever even it can get your
spouse yeah you can get it you can get
us in trouble right like I don't want to
just just pin it on on the children but
here's a plug for childhood 2.0 the
documentary on YouTube is free childhood
2.0 that's exactly what they're telling
you that it's this device man that
really unlocks Pandora's Box
on Snapchat one thought it'd be a funny
idea to talk the other one into
committing suicide and she did it she's
dead after about six weeks we were able
to crack his phone kids right now are
going to experience the worst of what
we're going through
how did your parents know that this
happens no no my kid won't do that my
kid would never my kid's school isn't
like that you're wrong because what they
see they feel neurologically compelled
to do
right now we're effectively living in an
experiment
how is this going to affect us we'll
find out
and that's why I think we need to to
properly build boundaries and and
healthy ways of exposing your child in
the appropriate times to sexuality I
liked our talk that we did the other day
um that really kind of just said hey
look you from the second that they're
born you are giving them a image of
sexuality
um no you're not describing all the
mechanics of how this works and how that
works and this and that but you're
modeling it from the start right and so
I think that we need to be conscious of
that and then age appropriately we need
to be giving them the proper picture so
another thought comes into my mind and
again because I was born in the 1960s
um I remember that pornography at that
time you had to actually go to a store
or you had to find it somewhere it
wasn't readily available like like it is
on our our devices now and they did an
interview with Ted Bundy and for people
who don't know who Ted Bundy was he was
a serial killer and he killed so many
women and he was a necrophiliac and he
said on the interview before he was put
to death he said that the reason why he
ended up becoming a necrophiliac and a
serial killer was because of pornography
it wasn't
listening I'm no social scientist and I
haven't done a survey I mean I I don't
pretend that I know what John Q's
citizen thinks about this
but I've lived in prison for a long time
now
and
I've met a lot of men who were motivated
to commit violence just like me
and without exception
every one of them was deeply involved in
pornography without question without
exception deeply influenced and consumed
by an addiction to pornography there's
no question about it the FBI's own study
serial homicide
shows that the most common
interest among serial killers
my experience with let's say pornography
generally but with pornography that
deals on a violent level with the
sexuality
um is it
once you become addicted to it and I
look at this as a kind of addiction
like other kinds of addiction of
addiction you keep I would keep looking
for
more potent more explicit more graphical
signs of material like an addiction you
keep craving something which is harder
harder something which which
gives you a greater essential
sense of excitement until you reach the
point where the pornography only goes so
far you reach them
that jumping off point where you begin
to wonder if if maybe actually doing it
will give you
that which is beyond just reading about
it or looking at it and this is the
comment that he made he said if
pornography use increases if more people
have exposure to pornography he said you
will see more people like me in the
future and if you
cleverly disguise it or even kind of
hide it in cartoons or yeah exactly
whatever children look at then you can
slowly educate them and then it looks
like they naturally develop that way
when really they were manipulated that
way I mean this this is going to get a
whole lot worse as we go along here but
you're seeing a trend here it's not only
going from the play toys but the media
but then into this is going to just be
progressively getting worse and worse
and worse until you know where's the end
of this thing yeah what's it actually
bringing the population to so I want to
show you a television show that came out
in the Netherlands as well ironically
um and um this was actually a very very
alarming to me on many levels I'll show
you and then we can talk about it
so it's a kids show and um what they're
doing is they're having full-fledged
adults come out on this kids show and
they will undress and actually be
completely Stark naked in front of these
young children for the whole show for
the whole show and the kids can ask
whatever questions they want to for uh
whatever reasons and again as long as
it's not sexual that's kind of like that
seems to be the
you know their defense mechanism well
it's not sick it's not sexual how do you
feel about this first of all I think
they get the adults to do this well I
think it's very ironic that well
unfortunately they didn't use very
attractive models either it's a
different cast each show so yeah so they
actually have all kinds of people with
tattoos
like old people that are young people
that are different races and so it's
designed so that the kids can ask
whatever questions they want to about
the human body and break down any sort
of body shaming yeah body positivity I
think it's different kids
and already I flunked right yeah but
what do you notice just about this image
that's on the screen right now well
they've blocked out all of the genitalia
so that I can't see it but the children
can that's a really good probably exact
perfect response there that's a really
good point so if it's okay for the kids
to look at it but it's not okay for me
to look at it that is a big red that's a
big flip I remember growing up and my
parents parents could watch things of
the child couldn't watch right but now
the parents can't watch what the
children are watching and and I just
really question the um you know the
mental state of all the people that have
to agree for this this is not one person
coming up with a hairball idea that
shocked the audience nobody knows what
we're doing this is this is a lot of
people agreeing to this yeah and then
and then even the response was not as
Grand in their country as it was
overseas overseas we were like mortified
like how could they do this with the
kids but well now it is important to
take into consideration that um many
places in Europe do allow
um nude bathing where they go into hot
tubs or not just hot tubs but on saunas
and families go into saunas all together
naked and and that's not an uncommon
practice and I think that they've taken
advantage of that it's not acceptable
here in the United States so maybe they
took some license with that whereas for
them it would be more acceptable than it
would be for us but but still it's like
for a child to see their parents naked I
think is different than to seeing total
strangers naked and I think that you're
opening up a door uh again for
um for abuse and for opportunities for
your children to be exposed to things
that that the parents can't control do
you think it takes away a form of
communication because that's easy you
know let's just take a fuller closing
points at things and and ask all these
obscure questions but um enable the
ability to explain something or be
creative in your explanation without
crossing any boundaries takes a level of
skill takes a level of thought takes a
level of creativity they're kind of
removing and even how the child
communicates with the people around them
when they have a question would they be
able to without Crossing Lines in other
societies I totally agree with that and
I and I didn't think that I would but as
you explained it that was the issue for
me when I went into
the sexual addiction that I began I
wanted to be loved by men and I wasn't
even necessarily so interested in the
sexual part but I had to participate in
that to get the love that I wanted and
that is a communication that's an
intimacy thing but in that culture and
as a sexual addiction grew I found that
even after having three you know uh
sessions in a day with different men
that the the intimacy was less and less
so the communication was changing and
what I was getting is always getting the
dopamine release which became the
addiction but I was really more isolated
and more alone even on a great day when
I had great conquests with different men
I still came away even more empty and
thinking well I need a better situation
or I need another one or I need another
fix after 20 years of that
living that life after 20 years it's
like if I connected with somebody it's
like don't tell me your name I don't
want to hear about your relationships or
your family whatever let's just do it
and get it over with it's interesting
because my communication drastically
changed and you know what I I couldn't
even have meaningful conversations with
people because I only objectified them
for what they could you know benefit me
for the moment sexually and then they
were discarded wow a great Point great
point you know I think it's very
interesting that
um back in the Garden of Eden Adam and
Eve have no shame no body shame
whatsoever and they got themselves into
a situation that really probably had
nothing to do with sexuality but
immediately they felt naked yeah and
they were just like I need to cover like
that that that was a human need to cover
it wasn't that it was just like whoa
whatever you know like let it all hang
out and it's funny that the devil has
like like Jesus covered Adam and Eve
right the devil has constantly pushed
man to take their clothing off to feel
no shame no no no no but I think there's
an aspect that you're missing here
because the devil doesn't just convince
us to take our clothing off he is the
one that wants to expose us you know
Adam and Eve were already naked but they
still had a covering of Light which was
Christ's righteousness right so when the
righteousness was removed through sin
then Satan was the one to expose him
haha look at yourself you're naked right
so the devil is the one that exposes us
but Jesus is the one that wants to cover
us and and I go back again to your your
analogy about the covering yeah you know
the cover is is not designed to uh
restrict us or to punish us it's to
protect us there we go yeah yeah it was
a that was a good illustration so yeah I
find this hugely disturbing that this is
this is starting to um be normalized off
something you said you were talking
about how Adam and Eve that was that was
a really good point because
they keep saying like the thing about
the women should be able to take their
shirts off and all that they're saying
no Society has made our breasts a sexual
object that they're really not they're
really just just like your chest no
difference I see a huge difference in
breast and chest but they say that
Society has taught you trained you to
look at them as a sexual thing and we
could get rid of that stigma if we would
just expose them and all that no you can
look at Aborigines and all that and they
walk around topless and they're not
getting raped and all this stuff but
what you're saying is it yeah nobody
taught Adam and Eve
to look at that as a shameful nakedness
or a sexual thing they felt it right
away they had nothing to compare that to
they they didn't have anything else
other than no other context other than I
did something wrong I need to cover yeah
the knowledge of Good and Evil that God
was trying to spare them from you know
now you have the knowledge of what evil
is and it exposes you and you see your
nakedness maybe I'm not quite
understanding but why would why would
they want to why would they want to
remove the sexual aspect from those
parts because naturally that's what it
takes to get someone excited right so
and and done in the correct way it's
something that brings glory to God that
was a gift from God so to kind of take
away the sexual aspect from our bodies
it's like but you have a good point that
you know even even in the art of a
married couple it's like you know
covering somehow increases the the
desire as well it's not just like you
know that's why why that's why there's a
whole Market of lingerie and things like
that it's like you're using the covering
as a way to sort of peak someone's
interest in that if you just remove all
that
you know you don't see it as special
anymore and it's not it's not a thing I
think there is that as well I mean I
think you you run the risk of just so
normalizing it that it doesn't become
the special thing that God intended it
to be yeah well people tend to look
better and close them without yeah this
is the truth
so um I wanted to read a couple of
things to you um the over sexualization
of of of anything and what what kind of
impact is that actually having on people
so this article was very interesting
um so if kids are exposed to sexuality
uh even before an age where they really
understand it what does this actually
can do to them listen to what this
article from Psychology today says
um even if a young child can't
understand sex or its role in
relationships the images they see can
leave a lasting impression its basic
premise of marketing that we that what
we watch read and direct our attention
toward influences our behavior and as
any marketer knows sex sells that's why
we see products and services that have
nothing to do with sex being marketed
and increasingly sexualized ways
toothpaste toothpaste toothpaste right
yep
um I saw a very interesting
um
um article on
in Denmark they're having a big problem
with the younger generation actually not
having babies so you know what they've
been doing oh yeah incorporating overly
sexualized imagery in in commercials and
trying to entice the population to
basically make more babies while we're
being told that the world is
overpopulated and one is fun and all
this stuff like because they're worried
about social
um
um uh what do you call it Social
Security because like the younger
generation's not putting enough in for
the older generation so the commercials
are really actually interesting they're
all the older generation the grandmas
like looking through picture books they
don't have any grandbabies like you know
like it's like only pulling at the
heartstrings like you're not giving the
elders trying to send their kids off
onto vacation honeymoons in Hawaii so
they'll get pregnant oh it's kind of
interesting but that you know yeah
that's so true it's like you know you
think of all the different ways that
that kids are exposed just through
normal commercials overly sexualized
things what is this impact having upon
us children is as young as eight and
nine are coming across sexually explicit
material on the internet and media
although research is just beginning to
assess the potential damage there is
reason to believe that early exposure to
sexual common content may have the
following undesirable effects that's
true it's still unknown there's still
tracking what the outcome is going to be
yeah that's interesting like we don't
you know for a long-term study you have
to be you have to have the evidence or
whatever so are we part of that project
to see what is sexual exposure to
children do well let's
let's start exposing children for 10
years and see what happens you know yeah
I actually found an article here but
it's more focused on the lgbtq community
but throughout the generations and the
name of the the title of the article is
society is changing it's by USA Today by
Susan Miller so back in 17 do you know
what percentage of the United States
population identified as lgbtq it was
like 0.4 1.2 is actually higher than
that oh interesting three
4.5 do you know what it is today 17
right no no it's probably like nine
no no it went up by a percent 5.6 but
that's still that's still alive but you
would think it was higher because of the
way the media portrays it that's not
crazy I mean I every time I'm in
eyesight of
some random mainstream television show
where I'm at it's like you always see a
main character being homosexual so you
would think wow and almost any room I'm
in there's probably a homosexual there
but that's not true according to the
statistics so it says an estimated 18
million adults identifies lgbtq so I was
thinking is it that you know they were
always there but they had they felt
concealed and now this is a a time where
they can open up or is it new people are
joining this this group or are now
coming into their identity so to speak
but the largest generation generational
period I guess that's a part of this
group is do you know which generation
and they make up uh 15.9 one in every
six gen zir
ifies as lgbtq we're growing out on
media that's normalizing it yeah and all
that too yeah it's not it's not cool to
be just straight yeah you know if you're
if you're bisexual you know or lesbians
gay transgender whatever that's much
more exciting over 50 of that number
identify as bisexual that's the highest
category yeah well well can I just kind
of add to that as a um as a person
growing up I've heard many stories also
of people that were gay but it was much
easier to tell the parent that they were
bisexual they kind of got the foot in
the door and then eventually they would
just say no I'm gay so bisexual is kind
of keeps the keeps the door open some
hope right maybe they're not fooling it
right so what are these undesirable
effects yep early sex is obviously kind
of seems like a no-brainer the more
you're exposed to it at an early age
probably the less likely you're going to
hold out for uh for marriage or
something you're going to be exposed to
sexuality yeah
of it if it's no longer special we can
engage yeah and unprotected yeah and I
mean that was the case when When We Were
Young I mean how many um you know
teenage movies or shows or things that
you saw that people were engaging in Sex
and you know that was normal so you kind
of think that's what a teenager is going
to deal with that's what that's what's
happening and that has that result but
interesting in those movies there
weren't actually teenagers there were
adults portraying teenagers so it's not
even reality you're actually kind of
hitting the nail in the head because
um in a lot of those teenager movies
there are laws against making people
work that are 18 and under so
um you cannot work them in the same ways
that someone is older so that's why they
look for somebody that's older so that
you you can actually work them for 12
hours out of the day and not have like
if they're under 18 years old on set
they have to have a teacher their parent
has to be there like you know there's a
lot of things that are going on there so
if the viewer doesn't know all of that
you just know all that so that's why if
you have someone who is actually an
older actor but looks like a teenager
they're going to take that person
because it's just easier for the
production wow so it also it adds a
layer of complexity there high risk sex
you know
um these are these are you know there's
never really the proper way of of
illustrating safe sex even really it's
just kind of whatever and that's going
to cause a problem you know Scotty I um
just a month ago was talking with a
young woman and she's in her early 20s
um a Christian she was raised in a
Christian home uh her and her brother
found a
DVD of pornography and they started
interacting sexually according to what
they saw and here the brother was
penetrating his sister vaginally and
anally according to what they saw in the
movie so children naturally imitate that
and that's not the only story that I've
ever heard of that but you know these
children naturally would not have gone
in that direction had they not seen this
and that they didn't have anyone else to
interact with and so that's what started
for this young woman
um you know this this addiction to not
only pornography but masturbation and
sexual acting out so let me ask you this
as a parent how can you
um I know that that you know you can do
the best job that you can to try to
prevent your children from being exposed
to pornography but
um you know what would be a way that
would kind of set in that child's mind
at an age-appropriate level that that is
not okay so that that you know is not
something that can
transpire yeah unfortunately Scotty I I
don't deal with that aspect so much um
as you do as parents you you guys should
be on the front lines of of of how to do
that
um I usually deal with it after it's an
issue and becomes a problem I think the
parents are the ones that are the first
line of defense with their children and
um even before pornography and sexual
things were as prevalent on the media
you know what we had um there was a lot
of kids that were being sexually abused
that didn't have parents that they could
come to and find protection or find
information and I know of another
situation where a little girl knew that
her parents told her if any anyone
touches you inappropriately you come and
tell us but yet she still felt like it
was a dirty thing and that after it
happened she still felt like she was the
guilty one and that she couldn't go to
her parents I think that communication
with your children at a very young age
keeping that line open letting them know
that they can come to you with every
anything that you're on not only
um a good source of information an
accurate source of information but that
you are the protector and that you do
care and that no matter what they
struggle with or what they've been
through that you will always love them
and if you can communicate that to a
child that's two or three years old then
as that communication is more open then
a child may come to you if it's six
years old and says hey you know I saw
this on the Internet or somebody at
church in the bathroom showed me this
video and then boom you know the parent
is like I'm glad you came to me that was
the right thing to do it may not stop
the fact that your child was exposed to
something
but you can deal with it that's right
and we call that damage control if
something does happen how can you
process it in a healthy way to help your
children not be slimed by it or trapped
in this in this um these feelings of
guilt and condemnation where they can't
share what happened to them so that they
can move along and be healed by that and
have productive lives good point good
point the saw came to mind I was
thinking how a parent can segue into
that kind of kind of conversation so
this illustration just popped to my head
so you parents can give me some feedback
um you guys dressed your children
obviously from Young he's probably not
you because you have older children but
um what if what if you use that so he
first goes the underwear then goes the
pants and so on and so forth so maybe a
lot of times we do things without
knowing why or we don't even think about
the why but to explain the why to your
children so as you're putting on the
underwear this is underwear
um it's worn for very different reasons
various different reasons one of which
is to protect so if someone try tries to
remove it or try to go behind this
barrier that's wrong you should come and
tell me like you think that would be a
good way or is that too much like no
okay I I think you know my my kids are
um 11 and 9 and we've had conversations
with them that we definitely have
allowed them the freedom to say you know
there are appropriate and inappropriate
ways that that people will interact with
you and so they're aware of the fact
that okay there could be some something
here that's not okay and so we've very
subtly you know obviously talked with
our children like it is not okay for
people to remove these things from you
and and kind of have that but that's
that's actually a good way to frame that
too this is a protection you know you
can even use your phone illustration
this is this is something that um you
know we value this and we want to to
make sure that it has protection on it
same way with you your clothes are
protecting you and right I I want to
follow up on that as well because in
design
form follows function and so what is the
function of the underwear so when you
dress a kid up in um Princess Leia
underwear or Spider-Man underwear you
know guess what I want to show people my
Spider-Man underwear you know if you're
putting a lot of lace and it's a
see-through silky material form follows
function what is the reason and the
purpose for wearing underwear and then
you put your kid in fancy sexy underwear
then guess what you're implanting those
principles no matter what you say that
the form is going to follow the function
Scotty just saw something about uh and I
think this is old too but there's an
outrage over some
toddler thongs that were being sold in
the mall or something just the word
alone just think about it toddler thongs
that's so wrong yeah first of all like
the adult thong I might have an issue
with even but it's a no-brainer yeah it
doesn't sound comfortable so I would
question the kid wanting to want to wear
something like that in the first place
because you know it's like you know
nobody wants to walk around with a
wedgie but didn't you didn't you say
that they they've studies shown that uh
they're seeing a lot of like young
preteens
because your children have been
sexualized that's right there's there's
a big problem with marketing and and
just pushing those things to younger and
younger audiences and that's where like
you know even the clothes like starting
out this conversation about the dolls
this this imagery is starting with the
dolls they saw a doll with a thong yeah
even though you are not necessarily
going to wear that at three and four at
eight nine and ten when you've got
companies producing thongs for that
demographic then there's a problem
sexual violence is something that this
article also says can become a problem
um and just early exposure to sexual
content may have a profound impact on
the child's values attitudes behaviors
towards sex and relationships and what a
beautiful thing that God has given to us
to share to bond us together it's the
glue that's supposed to keep married
couples together and you know the devil
is just trying to break up any
relationship that we have in any way
shape or form and one of the ways is to
not make that glue stick or to make that
glue just stick to everything yeah you
stick to everybody and so um you know
anything that you can do to basically
preserve the natural
bonding thing that God has created for
us using our sexuality making it
something special making it something
that is not freely given to whomever
comes along
yeah and that's what you know families
are are made of and this is something
special that you know only Mommy and
Daddy get to share together and when
you're you know you know of the age that
you can get married to you have this
special thing that you can share with
that person and I think that
um setting that proper context of the
sexuality I hopefully will give that
child a a chance to enjoy the gift that
God gave us let's know how this article
ends here for most families Banning
media in the home isn't a realistic
option after all most eight to 18 year
olds devote in an average of seven and a
half hours of media in a typical day
according to a 2009 study by the Kaiser
Family Foundation that's 11 years old
and more than half of that content
contains sexual images or references or
the goal isn't to avoid the issue but to
approach it on a head-on so that your
children learn about sex and
relationships from their most trusted
source which is you which is what we've
been talking about yes and so I I know
we're kind of discussing this from the
angle of oh my goodness like I can't
believe they would show that on on on
the media perspective but hopefully
that'll be kind of a bit of a shock
value to say okay I better get my act
together and my game plan together
because this is what's coming down the
road
um Keith you want to explain this one so
this one's just saying the same thing
basically but it's updated it's from
April 2020 exposure to sexually explicit
media and early adolescence is related
to risky sexual behavior in emerging
adulthood so this is such a
contradiction what they say it does is
what they're promoting right the whole
idea is to promote healthy sexuality you
know I go back to that um to the uh sex
education that they wanted to implement
in the EU six years ago basically
teaching zero to four year olds how to
enjoy masturbation how to teach them
after that how to experience huh you
said
zero to four preschool yeah I even have
the the YouTube link to it but the whole
idea is that by the time your children
are between the ages of 12 to 15 they
want to teach them BDSM which is
sadomasochism because they've taught him
everything else and this to me is such a
contradiction it says exactly what the
science is but then they twist it around
and say no no it doesn't do that but we
we feel that your children deserve to
know how to experience sexual behavior
that's enjoyable for them at a very
young age yeah well this article isn't
this is more of like they're just
noticing that it this is what happens
they're not condoning it but the school
is condoning or the school is is is
going to ignore this science and say no
no that's a lie yeah they will so this
is what they came out of it with two
important results first sexually
explicit media exposure and early
adolescence was strongly related to
three risky sexual behaviors and those
three are early sexual debut unsafe sex
and sexual partners in late adolescence
and this relationship was very close to
Collegeville casual no you said sorry
yeah second the association was dose
response such that using more modalities
of sexually explicit media led to higher
probability of being involved in Risky
sexual behavior later in life so the
more you're exposed the more likely it's
going to happen
and then they finish it off with saying
given that the negative consequences of
risky sexual behaviors such as STIs and
unplanned pregnancy have tremendous
social costs to both Western and Asian
societies it is necessary to implement
preventative strategies early on
so they're in conclusion it's like look
the more you kids get exposed to this
kind of stuff the more they're gonna
engage in Risky behaviors the more
they're going to do it early so we need
to have preventative strategies in place
to prevent that because it's it's risky
and damaging
at later points in life and that's the
part that everybody's not looking at is
like what that is the long-term effect
you know like what is that going to do
to their the state of their mental
health what is it going to do to them
physically
um you know what kind what if they pick
up an STD what if you know there's all
kinds of
um
things out there so from a spiritual
perspective this has to happen and end
times it will be as it was in Noah's
time yeah and that's what can we do you
know in the beginning when when you guys
were saying it was that it was kind of
shocking I was sitting there thinking
well it's not really that shocking
because the Bible tells us it's going to
happen and that the world is just going
to get worse and worse so you know it's
kind of like from today forward it
doesn't get any better right and that's
every day
so we should expect it to be as the
Bible says like it was in the days of
Noah
um you know it uses some interesting
language there it says they were eating
and drinking you know before they all
went to the argument it doesn't say why
well eating and drinking like well
what's the big deal people still eat
they drink because they were married and
given in marriage but even though people
did all those things the reason I think
it mentions them is because it's in
direct contradiction to the way they're
supposed to be done to giving glory to
God that's the problem it's not that you
know people didn't do those things then
it's not that people don't do those
things now it's the way that they're
doing them right so you said uh the
other day on the other show about
whatever all things you do whatever you
eat and drink and do it to the glory of
God that's right and looking back at the
time of Noah it's not just the bad stuff
it was also a glimmer of hope because
God looked at the Earth and he found a
family that was still living according
to biblical principles and it's going to
be the same at the end of time there
will be that special people that follow
are following God's commands no there's
been many examples of that God never
brings judgment upon his people
in the days of Sodom and Gomorrah a lot
he was like was it lot or was it Abraham
Abraham Abraham was asking yeah you know
would you destroy the righteous with the
wicked if you know what if there's only
ten what if there's only five and God's
like oh
yeah you know God he's so long-suffering
and compassionate that he's waiting
until like
so there's really no other option like
these people are gonna destroy
themselves especially with lot because
you know it's like when he chose the
part of the the land to live in you know
what does he do he migrates down to
Saturday right and it's like you know
God manages to get him out of there and
he and he's like well what about the
next town over I mean it's just like
isn't that human behavior isn't that
human behavior I would do the same thing
yeah so how close can I actually get
they had to grab his hands I mean the
Bible says that the Angels took him by
the hand and drugged him out of the city
like that's how much God was like you
know I'm you're not going to make this
decision I'm going to help you
and his wife was lost because of his
hesitation yeah that Spirit of Prophecy
says that yeah but that's the Bible says
like if it were possible even the very
elect will be deceived remember in that
City he had family that's right his
children you know they wouldn't go yeah
so I understand the angels having to
remove because that's hard yeah it's
difficult you know your family's left
behind well let's bring up a couple of
these Bible verses because I believe
that the devil is aiming at trying to
attack everybody and an easy target is
peel apart their sexuality right if you
can twist that you can twist a lot of
things about somebody's relationship
with God and so
um listen to what the Bible says um
because I think there's some things that
we can draw out of this let marriage be
held in honor among all God designs
sexuality he designed marriage to be a
blessing and and let it be
um the marriage bed be undefiled for God
will judge the sexually immoral and the
adulteress
so you see the devil's looking at this
and he understands you know what if this
act is done within the context that God
has designed it to be done then it's a
blessing but if I can remove them from
that God will judge them and so and we
want to be very careful to guard those
those Avenues very well and um it's very
easy in today's society to to
mess up our sexuality listen to what
First Corinthians 6 9 through 11 says do
you not know that the unrighteous will
not inherit the kingdom of God do not be
deceived neither the sexually immoral
nor the idolaters nor their adulterers
nor men who practice homosexuality nor
thieves nor greeting nor drunkards nor
revelers nor swindlers will inherit the
kingdom of God and
such were some of you Hallelujah but you
were washed you were Sanctified you were
justified in the name of the Lord Jesus
Christ by the spirit of our God so
that's not a work that we do that's only
a word that he can do if I could just
make this point because I think this is
so powerful I think that we as
Christians get get caught up in this
idea that that
we lose the
um the opportunity to tell people that
this is not behavior modification and
some people can actually overcome some
of these issues on their own but what
we're talking about is a Divine
transformation and and I think that we
as Christians should be offering
something more than what the world can
give them you can get behavior
modification all you want out there in
the world but only through Christ such
were some of you but you were washed
Sanctified and justified in the name of
the Lord Jesus Christ so that lets us
know that it's something higher than
what I can attain to for myself and that
I think is is the most powerful part of
that verse is it recognizes the things
that won't be in heaven but it also
shows me the way out of those things and
you know what I can find my name in
several of those things but only through
Jesus Christ can I find the way out
that's right First Corinthians 6 also
goes on to say flee from sexual
immorality every other sin a person
commits is outside of the body but the
sexual in sexually immoral person sins
against his own body or you do not know
that your own body is the Temple of the
Holy Spirit within you whom you have
from God you are not your own for you
were bought for the price so glorify God
in your body I think this verse just
highlights that we really don't even
know how
awesome this gift is you know it's
saying it's specifying sexual immorality
is something on a whole new level it's a
sin against yourself well I feel like
drinking and doing drugs and overeating
is a sin against myself but apparently
this is on some whole different level
you know it it it also is I like the way
it puts it at the end you are not your
own think about that for a second if
you're not your own who's are you Gods
right you're either gods or somebody
else's right and who do you want to have
ownership over your life do you want
somebody who has your best interest at
heart or do you want somebody who
doesn't have your best interest at heart
so if you if if God is saying look I I
own you but I own you in a way that I'm
going to give you Liberty and freedom
from
you know anything that would destroy you
versus another task master you know to
the devil and Satan which says he will
try to own you and say no no look it's
my way and you will be my slave and I
will make you miserable he might dangle
the golden care in the beginning but
we're not our own which means we have a
responsibility
it to come to God and say God
how would you have me to live right you
you you own me you want the best for me
you created me
so what do you have for me what's what's
what's the best that you have to offer I
want that instead of now I'm going to do
it my way I mean we're so broken we
can't get it right
it's interesting Keith because I I can
appreciate your your line of reasoning
there but I think to the average person
that isn't charged that could be a very
difficult thing to swallow about I'm I'm
a slave of God or I'm owned by God and I
have to do what he says that's not a
contemporary concept right right but but
I think what is fair to say that in
Isaiah 1 18 it says come and let us
reason together and that Jesus or God
doesn't pull me in you know and drag me
in um it has to be my choice and and in
that reasoning together even looking at
it like okay I could be a slave of gods
or I can be a slave of sin so when I
look at those two you know sin gives you
fun for a season it was a lot of fun
trust me it was a lot of fun but God has
to offer us something better so being a
slave to God is much more rewarding much
much more beneficial much more pleasing
than anything that I experienced in the
world but I think it's I I think I think
you you kind of miss this idea that when
we say that when you're a slave of God
that people that are on Church would
automatically just shut that down yeah
but but there is a reason why being a
slave of God is much more beneficial
because it also provides protection and
and
um and other benefits that you don't get
when you're under the slavery of sin and
self even even the world I think we
discussed this recently you're going to
be a slave of something yeah you're just
leaving somebody yeah and so you know
definitely I I understand from a
Biblical perspective that um we're we're
serving God and so you know I know the
Bible kind of interchanges those kind of
Concepts and stuff like that so
um maybe it's a good a better approach
to say you know is it better to serve
sin or better to serve God and with this
it's interesting to me that the same
activity can be so detrimental to you
and your psyche and everything then if
it's done in the context that God has
set it up in it can be actually an
absolute blessing yeah I mean it's
really the same act if you think about
it no it is it really is a blessing yeah
I mean like you said the same act it
could be like Satan's like I want I want
to give you sex with everybody you're
going to get STDs you're gonna have
abortions on one of pregnancies and
God's like I want to give you the same
thing but I want to give you the best
sex or the best partner it's gonna be
forever and you know like we've read the
statistics that married couples have the
best sex you know right God wants to
give you the best Satan just wants to
give you the scraps or the counterfeit
you know as you said that and you were
talking about the link with uh immoral
sex and psyche issues you want to tell
them about the episode we shot with Chad
that delves deeper into that do you
remember the title
ah let's see what was the name of that
one no love and marriage okay porn and
then there was porn on the brain part
too I'd highly recommend checking those
episodes out yep we hope that this was a
profitable conversation to anybody
that's watching of course this is uh
barely scratching the surface
um but we hope and pray that that you
guys will really take to heart some of
these principles and if you have
children or you are
um you know a parent and and you're
trying to make decisions on how you want
to to
um expose your children to the proper
ways here
um we pray that you will prayerfully
consider some of the things that were
said today
um come up with a plan and um when in
doubt God will direct your paths so ask
him the best way to proceed and we pray
that uh you guys enjoyed this talk thank
you so much for watching and we'll catch
you around on the next topic
somebody
[Music]
I am the god of the new world
I love anime
I love it I mean I can't watch enough of
this it's the tools who they say can
speak with the spirits the sins will
destroy the Commandments forever a
suspicious list of names prompts an
investigation at a local school and
concern from parents the Death Note is
derived from a Japanese animated show
the girl told authorities she got the
idea from a Cartoon Network show
S
I recognize that voice anywhere
shake it
[Applause]
[Music]